the Angry Birds movie wasn't  well-received  but that's not stopping a second movie  from coming our way I'm Tony and this is  your wing it GameSpot news update the  Angry Birds movie sequel is in the  planning stages game developer rocio's  CEO Katy lever anta stated as much  though no further details were given the  first movie featured the voice talents  of comedians like Jason Sudeikis and  Josh GAD and it's writers included  Simpsons scribe John vide considering  the movie made almost 350 million  dollars a sequel that brings this team  back together makes perfect business  sense Rovio's biggest hit may be Angry  Birds but the studio has quote several  exciting new games and other projects  and development including new IP when  the team announces that next game you'll  hear about it from GameSpot and for all  the biggest news on mobile games and  their movie counterparts  you're already in the right place